dans l'actualité ce soir la tempête sur
les marchés financiers la célèbre banque
d'affaires américaine lehman brothers se
déclare en faillite
victime de la crise des 'subprimes' les
bourses plongent paris perd près de 4%
des précisions sur la taxe pique nique
sera de 90 centimes d'euros par kilo
d'assiettes ou verres en carton
rien n'est encore fixé définitivement
pour le bonus malus sur les autres
produits la fin de la visite du pape en
france sa dernière messe a été consacrée
aux malades à lourdes devant soixante
dix mille fidèles
il a rejoint le vatican ce soir ils sont
les indésirables de l'europe un sommet
européen est consacrée aux roms
demain à bruxelles 10 millions de
personnes sur le continent
qui sont-elles comment vit-elle celle
dossier de cette édition la méditation
sort de son ghetto elle est même
recommandé désormais par certains
médecins contre la douleur ou la
dépression est ce vraiment mesurable
notre enquête dans un instant enfin
tétraplégique et champions le français
david smétanine est l'un des héros des
paralympiques à pékin il a accompli
aujourd'hui sa quatrième médaille en
natation
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous sans être
spécialiste de la finance il y a des
noms prestigieux que chacun connaît
rothschild morgan ou lehman brothers
et bien c'est cette dernière banque
d'affaires qui a ruiné aujourd'hui elle
annonce sa mise en faillite c'est un
coup de tonnerre dans le monde
économique est aussi le signe que la
fameuse crise des subprimes ce n'est pas
du tout terminé sophie brune burn in
here in new york hier soir
après un week-end de tractations la
nouvelle tombe lehman brothers ce ne
sera pas sauvé la quatrième banque
d'affaires américaine est en faillite
sans attendre des employés viennent
vider leurs bureaux c'est terrible
terrible ramasse toutes nos affaires
parallèlement un autre établissement de
renom merrill lynch est rachetée par
bank of america un séisme inédit selon
l'ancien gourou des marchés alan
greenspan
wang xin c'est la crise la plus grave
sans doute je suis un siècle
la conséquence sur les bourses et
immédiate dans la nuit en asie puis ce
matin en europe les marchés plongent
exemple à francfort où l'indicé vedette
perd 3 et demi pour cent 15h15 à paris
dans cette salle de marché où toutes les
statistiques c'est l'heure de la
production industrielle américaine sans
surprise elle est mauvaise 9h30 heure de
new york
l'ouverture de wall street toute la
planète finance a les yeux rivés sur le
marché américain
à paris on attend les cotations avec
angoisse c'est pas courant d'avoir comme
ça dès le lundi autant d'infos autant
on attend une prévention 16h à londres
dans le quartier des affaires la
faillite de lehman brothers menace 4000
emplois ces salariés gardent le silence
mais ont déjà fait leurs cartons
bonsoir alain de chalvron vous êtes en
direct à washington cette faillite c'est
un choc très important pour toute
l'économie américaine oui écouter on ne
parle que de ça ici d'abord parce que
l'amérique est une nation d'actionnaires
chacun est directement touché ensuite
parce que personne n'imaginait que des
sociétés comme lehman brothers aussi
prestigieuse aussi ancien 158 en plus un
jour s'effondrer et puis il ya aussi un
vrai sentiment d'inquiétude jette encore
de panique mais d'inquiétudes
est ce que le gouvernement en acceptant
pas de subventionner lehman brothers de
sauver lehman brothers la tipp ce
gouvernement n'at-il pas pris un risque
inconsidéré celui d'un effondrement des
marchés comme en 1929 le new york times
dit aujourd'hui que le secrétaire au
trésor joue à la roulette russe
financière ça passe ou ça casse
c'est justement là pourquoi est ce que
l'état n'a pas nationalité lehman
brothers comme il l'avait fait la
semaine dernière on en a parlé pour deux
grandes institutions de crédit oui alors
ces deux grandes institutions freddie et
fannie
ça aurait été une catastrophe pour toute
l'amérique et pour chaque américain
si on ne les rend fous et pas mais voilà
maintenant on a l'impression que c'est
chaque jour qu'il faudrait renflouer des
sociétés tant la crise est en train de
faire boule de neige et ça n'est tout
simplement pas possible ce n'est tout
simplement pas possible pour le
gouvernement et la réserve fédérale de m
des dizaines voire des centaines de
milliards de dollars sur la table chaque
jour alors le signal est clair c'est
débrouillez vous débrouillez vous aider
et les vouer le ciel vous aidera en fait
le gouvernement et la réserve fédérale
compte sur la capacité paris je dirais
plus sur la capacité du système
financier de trouver des solutions en
interne
alors c'est vrai que c'est un pari
risqué merci alain précisément une image
celle de george bush qui est intervenu
publiquement et il se veut rassurant et
il se dit confiant dans la faculté des
marchés à faire face à long terme à
cette crise
certains économistes sont beaucoup plus
inquiet alors on s'arrête
quelle est l'origine de cette crise
jusqu'où peut-elle aller la france est
elle concernée
éléments de réponse avec jean paul
chapelle et bruno girodon comment en est
on arrivé là
printemps 2007 les premiers panneaux à
vendre apparaissent aux états unis
personne ne soupçonne alors l'ampleur de
la crise à venir elle va faire des
millions de sans abri ils ont souscrit
des prêts immobiliers mais à taux
variables les fameux subprime face à la
hausse brutale des taux d'intérêt ils ne
peuvent plus rembourser et se retrouvent
à la rue des maisons à vendre que
personne n'achète l'immobilier craque
les banques qui ont investi dans
l'immobilier font faillite à leur tour
c'est la litanie des fleurons de la
finance qui s'écroule vers stearns
fannie mae freddie mac est aujourd'hui
lehman brothers
jusqu'où ira la crise là c'est l'inconnu
si une banque fait faillite
elle ne peut plus rembourser ses dettes
aux autres banques depuis hier le risque
de contagion est réel ça n'a pas de
précédent jusqu'à présent on était
terrorisé à l'idée qu'une banque
d'investissement faisant faillite par un
jeu de dominos par un jeu de cascades
tout le système financier soit
contaminée c'est le le fameux risques de
la crise systémique
et bien hier on a accepté le risque de
la crise majeure en laissant une grande
banque d'investissement faire faillite
première conséquence la bnp doit rayer
d'un trait de plume 180 millions d'euros
que la banque américaine ne pourra pas
lui rembourser pour dexia autres banques
françaises ces 500 millions d'euros de
perdus des banques de plus en plus
fragilisé ça facilite pas les
investisseurs les investissements la
croissance économique le crédit devient
plus cher c'est ça le même effet si vous
voulez qu'une augmentation des taux
d'intérêt alors quelles conséquences
pour notre économie
là encore c'est l'effet domino des
banques en difficulté qui ne prêtent
plus c'est la pénurie de crédit moins
d'argent c'est moins de consommation et
moins d'investissements la crise de
confiance est aussi contagieuse en
france on a déjà révisé à la baisse les
prévisions de croissance
on a constaté bien entendu le
ralentissement économique quand quand le
taux de croissance prévisible et révisé
de à 8 1 3 autre conséquence très
concrète la crise de l'immobilier en
france les ventes sont en chute libre
pas de confiance peu de crédit le cercle
vicieux est en route
et puis à noter que dans le sillage des
bourses les cours du pétrole ont encore
dégringolé passant sous les 97 dollars
le baril à new york le niveau le plus
bas depuis six mois
autre image aux états unis de jour en
jour on se rend compte de l'ampleur des
dégâts provoqués au texas notamment par
l'ouragan ike le texas où l'on distribue
des vivres et de l'eau des autoroutes
des ponts des plateformes pétrolières
vont rester fermées pendant des mois
peut être plus un couvre-feu nocturne a
été imposé pour éviter les pillages
en france d'abord des précisions sur ce
qu'on appelle déjà la taxe pique nique
information france 2 signé florence
mavic le chiffre de 90 centimes d'euros
par kilo de vaisselle jetable ne
s'applique pour l'instant cause assiette
au couvert en carton le reste devra
faire l'objet d'arbitrages c'est le cas
aussi l'arbitrage qui n'est pas encore
rendue pour la liste exacte des autres
produits concernés par le bonus malus
on sait qu'il est question des
téléphones portables des ordinateurs de
la peinture des frigos ou encore de la
lessive
il faut savoir qu'un pays appliquent
déjà ce système
c'est d'ailleurs là bas qu'est née
l'expression taxe pique nique il s'agit
de la belgique
reportage sur place elle a pas nos
fourchettes verres en plastiques films
transparents ou encore papier aluminium
depuis juillet 2007 tous ces produits
sont surtaxés en belgique de 3 à 4 euros
58 kg les consommateurs prennent ça plus
ou moins bien je pense qu'il faut
inciter les gens justement à cette
sensibilité écologique et que ça soit
pas naturellement donc ça peut être un
moyen je trouve que le gouvernement
prend vraiment de droite et gauche
beaucoup des choses déjà que ma note
elle s'allonge de jour en jour mais en
tout cas au niveau de ce qui était
papier alu et film plastique oui la
différence est vraiment importante
la grande distribution estimé il ya un
an que cette taxe allait faire doubler
le prix de certains produits
aujourd'hui les responsables avouent
pourtant hors caméra avoir réduit leurs
marges pour continuer à vendre et pour
le gouvernement
l'opération va ce malgré tout un succès
la preuve la taxe a beaucoup moins
rapporté que près la première année on a
touché 5 millions la deuxième année on a
après oui moi 9 millions donc on est
habillé pour cent de la valeur de ce que
ça aurait dû rapporter et il en déduit
bien sûr que les achats ont baissé
pourtant les écologistes ne semble
vraiment pas convaincu de l'efficacité
de cette taxe
manifestement dans le système belge a
n'a eu aucun impact parce que ça a été
improvisée parce que la transparence
n'ont pas non plus été répercutée
directement aux consommateurs ils voient
pas clair par rapport à ce qui se passe
mais toutes les parties s'accordaient à
dire aujourd'hui que l'impact sur
l'environnement est extrêmement
difficile à mesurer de nouveaux éléments
dans la sphère de l'agression des trois
jeunes de confession juive il y a dix
jours dans le 19e arrondissement de
paris
cinq personnes sont actuellement en
garde à vue l'enquète ne privez ligier
pas la piste antisémite
pourtant indiqué très vite par la
ministre de l'intérieur
hier michèle alliot marie on s'oriente
peut-être vers une bagarre entre bandes
audrey goutard andré germain lorsqu'ils
sont agressés le 6 septembre dernier les
trois jeunes hommes marchent dans cette
rue du 19e arrondissement
un groupe de cinq personnes les aurait
provoqués en leur envoyant un projectile
s'ensuit une bagarre générale kevin
détend et ses amis sont légèrement
blessés les agresseurs en fuite
immédiatement se pose la question d'un
nouvel acte antisémite
moi j'ai vu une équipe à mes deux
copains avec qui part dans la rue on
était plus d'une centaine c'est nous qui
ont riposté moi qui prends le caillou eu
des insultes à caractère antisémite pas
d' insulte anti sémite et pourtant les
associations juives réagi même la
ministre de l'intérieur michèle
alliot-marie montent au créneau pour
elle pas de doute l'agression et rassis
et pourtant les déclarations des cinq
suspects arrêtés ce matin mettent à mal
ce scénario les jeunes gens âgés de 16 à
23 ans reconnaissent est à l'origine de
la bagarre mais réfute toute motivation
raciste
l'un d'eux est d'ailleurs lui même de
confession juive selon les premiers
éléments de l'enquète on est loin de la
sphère rudy ce jeune juif violemment
agressé deux mois plus tôt quasiment au
même endroit dans ce dossier trois
personnes ont été mises en examen dont
deux pour tentative de meurtre et
violences à caractère antisémite
la justice encore avec sept erreurs
judiciaires retentissantes sept ans
après les faits un homme accusé condamné
pour un crime a été mise hors de cause
il s'appelle marc machin il va retrouver
la liberté dans quelques jours pour la
première fois il est sorti du silence
aujourd'hui fannie stellaire pascal
caron la justice
cet homme vient de passer près de 7 ans
en prison pour un crime qu'il n'a peut
être pas connu celui de marie agnès
bedot retrouvée morte au pont de neuilly
en 2004 marc machin c'est son nom est
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion
criminelle
mars 2008 tout bascule un autre homme
s'accuse de ce même heure il est
confondu par les tests adn
fait rarissime la justice envisage de
libérer marc machin mais il va rester en
prison trois mois supplémentaires pour
avoir frappé un surveillant
cet après midi le tribunal a décidé
qu'ils sortiraient à la fin du mois
interview étonnante en pleine cour du
palais de justice tant que seraient pas
acquittés réhabiliter ce qui me revient
de droit légitimement confiance est un
bien grand mot
donc comme vous savez n'oubliez pas que
ce mur que c'est une surprise
toutefois la justice qui a ils ont fait
que réparer leurs erreurs tout
simplement les sortes doriz une accolade
avec son verre présents chaque jour de
ses sept années de détention aux
entraînements avec l'espoir de le voir
bientôt sur coup là je vais faire le
couillon une fois libre une autre
bataille s'engagera celle de la révision
de son procès depuis un siècle seuls six
affaires ont abouti en bref l'enquète
semble piétiner sur la disparition du
petit antoine à issoire dans le
puy-de-dôme elle sera longue et
difficile a indiqué tout à l'heure le
procureur de clermont-ferrand
on le sait l'hypothèse d'une fugue n'est
plus aujourd'hui privilégiée et puis des
précisions sur le fichier edvige
finalement il n'y aura sans doute pas de
loi un nouveau décret sera élaboré dit
on au ministère de l'intérieur un décret
qui pourrait faire passer à la trappe
les indications sur les pratiques
sexuelles la santé et même l'ensemble du
fichage des personnalités c'est demain
que se tiendra à bruxelles un sommet
pour la première fois sur les roms cette
minorité
souvent mal considérés et qui fait même
l'objet de mesures directes en italie
par exemple
le problème est devenu politique les
roms seraient 10 millions au total
qui sont les indésirables de l'europe
comment vivent style c'est le dossier de
cette édition il est signé pierre monnet
gier philippe muge rhin ils ont dix ans
à peine et leur école c'est la rue pas
question de laisser échapper une pièce
tombée par terre il y a toujours un
membre de la famille qui surveille les
adultes sont là sur le trottoir
le grand-père le père et un oncle qui
semblent diriger le groupe
pourquoi ces enfants ne vont pas à
l'école
chacun d'eux rapporte 10 euros par jour
c'est sa réponse
10 euros c'est aussi ce que gagne roux
salines à 14 ans il a déjà ce qu'il
appelle un métier ferrailleurs le clip
banier
j'ai vécu 3 euros 50 le kilo alors il
faut en ramasser de la ferraille son
oncle daniel nous montre ses mains à guy
mais à force de faire les poubelles de
saint qui fait mal aux mains oui c'est
ça les ferait passer les mains de
travailleurs pas de voleurs non non non
mais les volets non c'est pas avant les
volets ils vivent à 10 dans ce squat au
milieu des chantiers
trois générations de 4 à 50 ans tous
ferrailleurs gitans roms des synonymes
pour le grand public rien à voir
répondre les intéresser les gens du
voyage sont français et nomades et il
n'aime pas du tout être comparés aux
roms complètement déjoué céder franck
roy seront là bas ça rase des rouges
nattawut je sais pas il s'empare nous
les manouches ici nous allons payer la
même que tu as faim on descend souvent
la même endroit cet endroit c'est le
rajasthan au nord de l'inde
le peuple rom commence sa migration au
12e siècle direction l'ouest et
notamment l'europe où il constitue
aujourd'hui la première minorité
ethnique
avec près de 10 millions de personnes
principalement dans les pays de l'ex
bloc soviétique mais aussi en europe de
l'ouest et notamment en france où ils
seraient près de 400000 la plupart
vivent dans des bidonvilles sans eau
sans électricité sans hygiène
médecins du monde envoie régulièrement
des bénévoles dans ce quart monde aux
portes des grandes villes françaises
ils ont quasiment sur les indicateurs de
santé les mêmes choses que dans les pays
les plus sous-développées salir une
espérance de vie à 54 ans un taux de
fécondité a 4 enfants par femme
avec toutes les pathologies qu'on
rencontre dans la misère
ils surveillent particulièrement les
enfants comme elie saigne 3 et vous
repérez de l'estomac en roumanie
les médecins lui ont posé une sonde
gastrique artisanale un simple tuyau
d'arrosage par lequel sa mère le nourrit
et pourtant un front social européen
existe richement doté 11 milliards
d'euros
parmi les projets mis en oeuvre des
villages d'insertion comme celui
d'aubervilliers en seine-saint-denis
cette famille a emménagé il ya un an
après des années dans la rue comment
pourquoi
qu'est ce qui arrive des mois à 8 ans
elle redouble son ce1
mais elle s'accroche et cette volonté
d'aller à l'école c'est justement le
principal critère pour bénéficier de ce
programme quoi il est 20 heures 16 si
vous nous rejoignez à suivre
l'enseignement sans école à l'occasion
de la journée de la liberté d'instruire
on verra que 30 à 40 mille enfants vont
à l'école ou à la maison ou chez un
particulier
la méditation sort de son ghetto elle
est même recommandée par certains
médecins contre la douleur ou la
dépression est ce vraiment mesurables et
puis champion est tétraplégique le
français david smétanine 33 ans est
l'une des vedettes des jeux
paralympiques avec quatre médailles en
natation
mais d'abord la fin de la visite du pape
en france sa dernière messe a été
consacré ce matin aux malades à lourdes
devant soixante dix mille fidèles
aurélia bros delphine parent et müller
salué par françois fillon
benoît c zéro parc hier en début
d'après-midi fin d'un voyage de quatre
jours derniers temps forts à lourdes ce
matin une messe pour les malades devant
soixante dix mille pèlerins la
souffrance endurée rouler c'est kylie
problème mieux assurée d'une vie il est
des cons pas que l'homme ne plus
soutenir seul sans l'aide
de la grâce divine devant lui 1500
malades ont patienté pendant des heures
pour le voir c'est émouvant parce que
c'est pas perdre les dirigeants m'ont
dit quand même
de l'huile sainte sur le front les mains
dit malades ont reçu l'onction des mains
même du pape
un geste important pour un chrétien que
beaucoup auraient aimé recevoir aimé
quitter l'eau sur les malades même que
ne soit pas lui on est de les avoir à
locaux aujourd'hui beaucoup de pèlerins
avaient déjà quitté lourde
le pape n'y a d'ailleurs pas connu le
même succès qu'à paris cent soixante dix
mille fidèles avec tout de même fait le
déplacement
l'éducation à chaque jour son annonce
hier nous vous parlions des récompenses
et des prix aujourd'hui le ministre
xavier darcos a indiqué sur france info
qu'il voulait instaurer un code de la
paix scolaire
l'idée est d'harmoniser les procédures
disciplinaires de tous les
établissements ils souhaitent aussi
proscrire l'exclusion des élèves
lorsqu'on évoque l'éducation on pense à
l'école au collège ou au lycée
mais il ya une réalité qu'on évoque peu
souvent celle des enfants qui sont
instruits en dehors des établissements
regardez ce chiffre ils sont tout de
même 30 milles au moins en france
il souhaite être reconnu une journée
leur est consacrée aujourd'hui certains
reçoivent un enseignement de leurs
parents d'autres se rendent chez des
particuliers souvent d'anciens
enseignants l'école sans l'école
reportage
josé blanc la pierre miquel cariou il
est 9 heures comme les autres ces
enfants se rendent à l'école jusque là
rien de particulier tout change en
revanche devant la forte ici pas de
préau mais un garage et dans les
cartables on est prié de ne pas oublier
ses pentes au
une maison école où l'on fait un peu
d'anglais chaque jour peu importe l'âge
et le niveau
alors faisons tous les jours de l'année
retrait puis travaux pratiques sur les
déchets avec une maîtresse tout terrain
qui expliquent toujours le pourquoi du
comment
si on ne le dit pas à quoi ça sert eh
bien ils risquent de ne passer
complètement à côté de l'apprentissage
et de ne rien retenir parce que ça n'a
pas de sens venu de donner du sens
adaptée à ses enfants plus intelligents
que les autres et pourtant
fâchée avec l'école c'est le choix de
cette enseignante du public qui met sa
carrière entre parenthèses et accepte de
gagner 500 euros de moins par mois pour
leur donner envie d'apprendre les
questions nationales ou les dames
confondus avec des sorties avec des
conférenciers avec des visites de
monuments et cetera dix élèves de 5 à 9
ans qui garde tous un mauvais souvenir
de leur école d'avant mais je n'ai pas
de coton j'avais subtil c'est une valoir
religieuses les jo gilles fois des
coffres si ma troisième école du sur
mesure qui revient à 400 euros par mois
à des parents prêts à mettre le prix
dans une solution qu'il cherchait
parfois depuis longtemps
il voulait plus aller à l'école offensif
il y est nous tous on a commencé à se
poser des questions les pions m'a
découvert une version de cette école
qu'il était très difficile d'adapter
l'enseignement à ma fille
c'est à dire éventuellement de la faire
progresser en français mais de tenir
compte de ces difficultés en
mathématiques
donc on a choisi une structure où elle
avance à son rythme et chaque vendredi
soir la salle à manger écoles reprend
ses droits pour la durée du week end
aures dans l'éducation mais sur un autre
continent avec une initiative vous allez
le voir spectaculaire celle du
gouvernement indien
on sait que là-bas l'inégalité entre les
sexes est criante on estime que 40% des
femmes sont illettrées
l'état a donc décidé de rémunérer
directement les jeunes filles pour les
inciter à reprendre le chemin de l'école
2 centimes d'euro par jour et par élève
pour la population indienne ce n'est pas
négligeable reportage arnauld miguet
dominique marotte
sanaa et fatima jo de leurs 15 ans ne
font pas l'école buissonnière bien au
contraire elles sont même devenus des
élèves modèles depuis que les autorités
ont décidé de donner une récompense pour
chaque jour de présence à l'école du
coup ça n'a peut s'offrir un petit
plaisir sur le chemin du collège
j'adore ses boucles d'oreilles et je
peux me les acheter parce que je vais à
l'école sanaa comme ses camarades de
seconde est aujourd'hui payer pour
répondre présent à l'appel
une petite roupies l'équivalent de 2
centimes d'euro par jour plus toutes
sortes davantage libre transport ou
uniforme gratuit en donnant un peu
d'argent on soulage les faits loin et
donc elles nous envoient leurs six plus
facilement les garçons eux sont exclus
de cette initiative publique mieux
scolarisés plus longtemps et collait
bien obligatoire en inde jusqu'à 14 ans
et 50 % des filles abandonnent cours et
récréation avant la fin de l'école
primaire
il est 14h sanaa rentrer chez elle elle
fait partie de ces 118 millions
d'enfants touchés par la pauvreté vivent
à 7 dans une seule pièce
l'éducation c'est donc pas une priorité
pour la famille c'est bien plus utile
pour elle d'apprendre la cuisine où les
tâches ménagères
ça lui servira plus quand elle sera
mariée et vivra avec sa belle famille
sinon ses beaux parents vont se demander
ce qu'on lui a appris mais c'est devenu
une priorité pour l'administration qui
tentent de renverser la tendance
on ne change pas les mentalités du jour
au lendemain il épie bande à l'école
elles ratent des opportunités d'emplois
grâce auquel elles peuvent gagner de
l'argent mais doucement on arrive à
changer les choses s'il en connaît un
boom économique sans précédant sa
situation en matière d'éducation reste
préoccupante avec 380 millions
d'illettrés l'inde détient un record
mondial en la matière en bref encore à
l'étranger un nouveau scandale
alimentaire secoue la chine du lait
frelaté pour nourrisson a été vendu à
des milliers de familles deux bébés sont
morts plus de 1200 sont malades
la poudre de lait étaient contaminés par
de la mélamine un produit chimique
utilisé dans la fabrication de
plastiques ou de colle la négligence et
la corruption sont une nouvelle fois
incriminés
et maintenant un peu de distance avec le
tumulte à la frontière de la santé de
l'art de vivre la méditation sort de son
ghetto cela peut faire sourire mais vous
allez le voir on est très loin désormais
de l'image des hippies attardés ou hors
du temps la méditation est même
recommandée par certains médecins contre
la douleur ou la dépression par exemple
alors ses effets sont ils vraiment
mesurable enquête marie pierre
cassignard pascal stelletta on dit de
lui que c'est l'homme le plus heureux du
monde
et il s'en amuse matthieu ricard moine
bouddhiste proche du dalaï lama
collectionne depuis 30 ans les heures de
méditation
quarante mille heures au compteur
l'équivalent de cinq années à si
immobile à faire travailler son esprit
ans aux estime considérablement le
pouvoir de transformation de l'esprit on
est prêt à faire de l'exercice physique
pour être en bonne santé on n'hésite pas
à passer 15 ans apprendre à l'école
avoir une formation professionnelle et
notre esprit qui à qui on a affaire du
matin au soir on laisse un peu en friche
c'est un peu dommage parce que nous
avons tous le potentiel d'un meilleur
équilibre émotionnel façon plus optimale
de vivre ce discours sur les bienfaits
de la méditation les scientifiques
aujourd'hui le valide
nous sommes à l'université du wisconsin
sur le crâne de matthieu ricard 256
électrodes depuis huit ans des
chercheurs analysent son activité
cérébrale lorsqu'il met dit
leurs conclusions sont spectaculaires en
pleine méditation
on mesure dans son cerveau une activité
électrique jusqu'à 8 fois supérieure à
celle d'un cerveau non entraîné
certaines zones qui habituellement
s'ignorent se connecte les unes avec les
autres et nous avons découvert des
réseaux dans le cortex préfrontal et
aussi à l'arrière du cerveau dans le
cortex pariétal et ces zones étaient
fortement active et est incomplète
synchronie pendant la méditation et pas
besoin de s'adonner à la méditation
depuis des années pour en sentir des
effets les scientifiques ont également
testé des débutants après seulement
moi à 30 minutes par jour la pression
sanguine et l'anxiété diminue le système
immunitaire se renforce application
directe de ses recherches aux états unis
quelques 200 hôpitaux utilisent déjà la
méditation pour traiter les personnes
dépressives et en france ça commence
ainsi dans cette limite de lyon ces
patients ont entamé un programme de huit
semaines pour apprendre à méditer
ils en sont déjà les premiers effets ça
apporte aux flots lèche de choses
positives telles que langil et la
scission l'envi de faire sourire les
gens l'envi de vivre ici on apprend à
repérer ses pensées négatives pour
éviter la rechute dépressive un exercice
exigeant
ça demande beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
de pratique
ça va demander aux patients de faire des
exercices quotidiens pour développer
cette qualité qui viendra ensuite une
seconde nature
a lyon les premiers résultats sont très
encourageants pour l'instant en france
seuls trois hôpitaux proposent cette
méthode
la journée mondiale du lymphome de quoi
s'agit-il d'un rouage essentiel de nos
défenses immunitaires une sorte de
système de drainage qui bloque les
substances étrangères dans le corps
humain mais il est fragile
il est en particulier prévu lé nez râble
au cancer en compte douze mille cas par
an trois fois plus qu'il ya 20 ans et
pourtant les traitements existent
explication jean daniel flaysakier mahdi
diawara très rassurant il n'y a aucun
nom mais lyon il y a cinq ans jean-marie
de l'as en série avait une masse
cancéreuse de 12 cm dans le vendent
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus rien les
résultats sont concordants pour montrer
que vous êtes en rémission complète et
que avec le temps évolue vers un
charisme en 2003 après un épisode de
grosse fatigue le diagnostic tombe c'est
pas lymphome un cancer du système
lymphatique
ce système c'est un filtre géant on y
trouve l'appendice les amygdales la rate
mais aussi les ganglions lymphatiques
sans qu'on sache pourquoi
ce filtre va un moment produire à
l'excès des globules blancs anormaux
c'est le lymphome
depuis vingt ans le nombre de cas a
triplé
c'est que certaines infections
bactériennes ou virales comme le sida ou
les hépatites peuvent être mise en cause
mais aujourd'hui le rôle de
l'environnement et de certains produits
est montré du doigt
il ya une profession qui est
particulièrement à risque
c'est la profession agricole et
l'exposition aux pesticides est une des
cause augmente l'incidence la fréquence
et lymphome d'environ deux fois plus il
faut signaler aussi que la manipulation
par des jardiniers du dimanche comme on
les appelle
deux de ces produits dangereux sans
précaution doit être évitée responsable
du personnel dans un groupe jean-marie
ne sais pas pourquoi il a eu ce cancer
dit là-dessus commence en effet cinq
séances nation pour moi j'y allais
quand pour un combat courageux y allait
pour gagner et c'était long oui c'était
long mais trois jours trois semaines
j'y allais pour gagner pour traiter les
l'info médecins des patients disposent
désormais d'une arme redoutable les
anticorps monoclonaux
ces nouveaux traitements vont
s'accrocher aux cellules malades et
entraîné leur destruction
voici à gauche alain forme du poumon et
de la plèvre deux mois après traitement
la tumeur a disparu comme jean-marie
cent mille personnes vivent aujourd'hui
guéris de leur l'info en bref une grande
soirée pour la télévision publique au
théâtre du châtelet à paris ce soir à
l'appel d'une quarantaine
d'organisations professionnelles de
l'audiovisuel soirée intitulée pour que
vive la télévision et alors que le
projet de loi sur le financement de
france télévisions sera présenté dans un
peu moins de 10 jours en conseil des
ministres image signée franck brisset
cinéma on connaissait la chanteuse
on connait c'est l'actrice madonna
devient réalisatrice son premier film
derrière la caméra obscénité et vertu
sera prêt demain il raconte ses débuts
difficiles les critiques sont disons
partager jean françois feer est
nous surprendre comment madonna le
pourrait-elle encore à 50 ans après 25
années au firmament
réponse avec son premier long métrage
derrière la caméra
contrainte de gueule obscénité et vertu
un titre étrange mais fidèle à un thème
celui du bien et du mal que la star a
développé tout au long de sa carrière
pour en parler la madone reçoit tarom
dans sa suite d'un 4 étoiles dix minutes
montrant matin je ne m'attends pas à ce
que ce film soit un succès critique ou
commerciales
c'est plutôt le mot carte de visite pour
venir me voila j'aimerais vous prenez au
sérieux
pour sa première réalisation
madonna raconte le quotidien de trois
colocataires londonien dont holly
apprenties danseuses elles rêvent de
gloire et de fortune mais que l'état la
place échec et d'échéance bref c'est un
peu l'histoire de madonna elle même
résumé en une heure et vingt minutes
pendant l'écriture du scénario je ne
savais pas que j'étais en train de
parler de moi mais quand j'ai vu le
produit final je me suis dit oh mon dieu
mais tous ces personnages c'est moi
madonna et c'est surtout de faire
oublier ses nombreux revers au cinéma
elle jure de ne plus jamais faire
l'actrice les critiques l'ont blessé
procès d'intention répond-t-elle
ahidjo ses critiques s'adresser à
madonna la personne ou à l'actrice vous
savez dans ce milieu les gens aiment
bien vous coller des étiquettes et vous
mettre dans des boîtes sans jamais vous
laisser la possibilité d'en sortir
obscénité et vertu n'est pas encore le
film qui l'a réconciliera avec la
critique
un brin provocateur original mais encore
hésitants dans la réalisation
la madone assume promet de faire encore
mieux la prochaine fois du cinéma
toujours avec l'image de deux grands du
cinéma américain de passage à paris
robert de niro al pacino côte à côte ils
sont venus faire la promotion de leur
prochain film la loi et l'ordre sortira
en octobre
un beau parcours maintenant il est à la
fois tétraplégique et champions le
français david smétanine est l'un des
héros des paralympiques à pékin il a
récolté aujourd'hui sa quatrième
médaille en natation
christophe duchiron frédérick basile sur
place à pékin comme on dit dans le
milieu des bassins c'est un gros bonnet
encourager en tribunes par le clan des
tricolores david smétanine nage est
aujourd'hui au couloir 4 avec une jolie
pancarte de favori dans le dos il nage
est aussi avec ses gros bras et sans
l'aide des jambes
david est tétraplégique partiel suite à
un accident de voiture à l'âge de 21 ans
sur le 50 m nage libre purée preuve
d'esprit il a fini en or et en émotions
un gros soulagement
soulagé d'en avoir terminé et alourdit
aussi du poids des quatre médailles
qu'il a remportée en huit jours deux en
or deux en argent lui qui faisait de la
natation avant l'accident et qui s'est
remis à l'eau très vite après car dans
l'eau il est dans son élément
bien sûr que musculairement on progresse
grâce à ça c'est évident et j'en trouve
identité aussi une personne qui était ma
personne donc
donc ouais une thérapie aime ça reste
une thérapie encore au nom du sport et
pour le sport et et c'est important car
il en faut forcément du talent de
l'énergie la volonté pour faire avancer
à plein régime ce corps dans l'eau
oubliez le corps d'avant celui de
l'intégralité des moyens physiques
à force d'entraînements ou images
parfois plus de 12 km par jour
david est devenu aux jeux paralympiques
un athlète de très haut niveau
je pense que david a à passer le cap où
il était à la recherche de
besson corps maintenant il ya à la
recherche de la performance et de la
perfection le handicap et accessoires
dans la natation du sport à ce quizz la
4e médaille des primes équivalentes à
celles des sportifs français des jeux
olympiques
il faut repartir de pékin avec 140 mille
euros dans les valises mais en fait avec
bien plus que cela
une manière de reconnaissance
et puis une image de football en ligue 1
hier soir en match en retard le psg
s'est imposé face au fc nantes 1-0 but
signé kezman sur penalty le psg avec 10
points se hisse donc à la troisième
place au classement derrière lyon et
marseille on a vu la faute d'une antenne
d'eau sur hoarau et la transformation du
penalty avant de refermer ce journal je
vous en rappelle l'un des principaux
titres la tempête sur les marchés
financiers
la célèbre banque d'affaires américaine
lehman brothers se déclare en faillite
victime de la crise des subprimes les
bourses plongent paris perd près de 4% à
washington george bush tente de rassurer
à paris christine lagarde écartent
l'hypothèse de faillite du même genre
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 cold case affaires
classées
23h15 n'oubliez pas complément d enquête
autour de benoît duquesne
au sommaire les soldats français en
afghanistan un mois après la mort de 10
que le militaire à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 pourrait faire
mais